[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to collider
for another
exclusive interview for one of my
absolute favorite shows of 2020 that is
kicking off season two in the new year
we are talking
zoe's extraordinary playlist with the
star of the show we have jane levy back
on the channel
and also choreographer mandy moore
congratulations more congratulations for
you jane and mandy i was telling you
before
so excited to meet you and to be able to
congratulate you on everything about
this show that i absolutely adore
thank you we're happy to be here all
right mandy i'm going to start with you
because i wanted to go back to the
beginning
a little bit of everything you worked on
before zoe
is there any experience you have that
you find coming in handy the most
now that might surprise you oh yeah
literally every job i've ever done
is helping me do zoe's you know i
you know obviously working on la la land
working so closely with damian and
and being able to craft dance for camera
really helped you know for zoe's and
um you know i walked into zoey's
thinking like man it's
good thing that i've done what i've done
in my career because it really is like
drawing on every single little thing
that i've ever learned
and kind of putting it right in front of
me every day when i come to work
so i love it so when you first signed on
to the show
did you know that jane was going to star
well i
knew jane's work when i signed on but i
i we'd never met before and so
um you know i remember one of our first
days meeting i think was
it was like maybe a dinner was the very
first meet we had but then we got right
into true colors rehearsal i think
like day one of meeting jane i was like
freddie nice to meet you
you're gonna dance with peter gallagher
hello touch
hands here we go let's do it so
during that dinner or wherever you had
your first meaty discussion together
about what you were gonna do
what did you need to know about each
other or
maybe mandy what did you need to know
about jane in order for you to do your
best work and then jane what did you
feel
was super necessary to tell mandy about
yourself so you could do your best work
basically anytime i work with anyone
who's gonna dance the
one number one thing i need to know is
do you know you're right from your left
like that's basically
it because the rest of it i can help you
know and i want to get in there and help
and coach and
and you know i remember you know what it
was jane we were in
that we had a crazy this is a good
little behind-the-scenes story
we in on the pilot had a dance studio
that was
basically rented out for us and it was
the upstairs of this
business building somewhere in downtown
vancouver and we actually had the cops
called
on us because we were making so much
noise
that the downstairs people called the
cops so that's the first time i've ever
had the cop shut down a rehearsal
but we were in there with richard our
director in austin and you know
obviously uh peter and jane were there
and
we started kind of breaking down true
colors and you know i
i just love jane's process like she's
like who what where when why
and i'm like great i love and then once
we get into that
let's figure out how we do it you know
what where when why how
that's usually how it works yeah i mean
also you know
zoe didn't really partake in the musical
numbers in the pilot
so i feel like i really got to know
mandy um prepping for
when we had gotten picked up and we were
going into season one and we started
with episode two which was a huge
boom right out the gate i got the music
in me i feel like that's when we really
got to know each other and how each
other work because during the pilot
you know i am mostly
first of all in the pilot we're all
together discovering what the show is
going to be and we're like
we're learning day-to-day and crafting
and collaborating and it's like being
formed in front of our eyes
and so you know i tell this story
sometimes because it's just
a funny anecdote like when i read the
script
you know there's a part of me that is
like you get to know me and i'm like a
very big softy but
there is a there is um an exterior that
you have to get through
and you know when i first read the pilot
i
was like okay this could be either
really moving or it can be so cringy to
have this man turn around and sing
true colors to me and you know it's just
such a wild
journey from me reading that and
thinking that and then the profound
experiences i had with peter that were
like extremely emotional and
pivotal for the series and my my career
as an actress it's just like
it's it's it's changed form over time
but like
at the beginning i was like i don't know
about this man seeing
true colors to me like i'm not sure yet
you know so i feel like that was sort of
the first um
rehearsal um and then you know on the
day
or through every rehearsal and then when
we get it on set it's always changing
shape
um but yeah i really got to know mandy
season one especially with i've got the
music in me because i think you were
like how does this girl move i i haven't
seen her move yet
and so she and jillian and jeff
had me move across the floor and that
was just that was such a fun number
yeah she came right after or to season
two and
you know we had a little bit of prep
which was nice never enough by the way
but we did have some prep
and i think literally our first
rehearsal was you walking in with and
jillian and jeff are the people that are
on my team as well and
yeah i was like let's just get you
dancing let's see what you grab on to
how does
zoey move we gotta find it speaking of
jillian and jeff mandy do you have any
unsung heroes on your team that you just
want to
make sure people know about their work
jillian
myers and jeffrey mortensen they are my
team they've been here since day one
and i could not do anything on the show
without them
they're they are great creators in their
own right and i'm
so lucky to have them as my associates
they just
we are team dance it's kind of a thing
we all do in production everybody knows
that we are team dance
it's not just me it's also my two amigos
so
we always do everything together and
they're the best
yeah i have to say witnessing mandy and
how she works has been
really inspiring for me because
you know she she knows exactly what she
wants and
i mean you are very um
decisive person incredibly creative but
you are also
and i think that's what makes you so
talented and creative is that you
you you listen and you like collaborate
and so
watching her and jeff work to and jilly
work together is really amazing and then
watching her work with cast and then
watching her work with austin like
she's the ultimate collaborator in this
way that i think that that's how you
make good stuff you know
i i mean i i don't know dance world but
i sort of have this idea that
you know the choreographer is like you
go here and you go here you go here shut
up and do it i don't know maybe that's
just like the cartoon version of a
choreographer you know but mandy is
just she sees very big
there's a very wide scope i have a good
follow-up to that but i want to blab
about something that you were just
talking about jane we talked about this
a little last time but i want everybody
out there to know
if you judged this show maybe by the
first little bit of promo material you
saw and think it's one thing
just know that it's so much more and for
anyone out there who has not watched
season one
please go check it out you have my word
it will not disappoint you
but going off of that idea mandy first
i'll throw this to you
of everyone in this ensemble who would
you say
had a process that kind of melded with
yours the most and then who challenged
you to adapt to what they needed the
most
as jane was just saying i really do try
to kind of
morph and mold to what's needed
especially with dance because i think
dance can be so vulnerable for people
and there's something that people just
have like
deep seated fear you know like even good
dancers it's like am i good enough you
know and then the people that don't
dance
like oh no i can't dance you know and i
maybe it's pollyanna but like i really
believe
anyone can dance and it's who am i to
judge what is good or bad
it's my life i am an expert at it but
it's also
very subjective if people move through
space that is dance to me so
as far as process goes really the no
i didn't find anyone challenging because
every single one is challenging because
that's part of my job
is to get to know how people tick
you know like what how they move do they
like
positive reinforcement do they like to
go bit by bit
do they want big picture do they want to
just keep going and laugh through it and
figure it out on their own
you know everyone really each cast
member has literally a completely
different
process of how they like to rehearse how
they like to get it up in front of
camera
and then ultimately what they want when
we're on camera that's a really
beautiful thing too is i love the days
of each different cast member being on
camera and like what they need
you know do they just want to be like
you're nailing it or that's a little
rough like something
j nose sometimes i'll just give an
eyeball like which is hard with the mask
i have to
say this season because usually i can
just give like a facial expression and i
know what i'm thinking
um but it's it is really individual i'll
say it's super individual between
every single one of them i'm gonna come
back to that but really
quick then given how you just described
the ensemble
who who is on like one side of the
spectrum and who is on a completely
different side as far as what they like
to do whether it's big picture or small
or anything else about the process
well i think you know i think jane said
this too before i've heard her say this
in interviews but you know she and mary
i think had probably the least amount of
experience
when it came to dance and music so
obviously the way that i
work with mary and jane is different
than somebody like say skyler or alex
who has a lot of experience moving
then somebody like john clarence he is
like i can't believe that guy wasn't a
dancer like he's a weird one to me in
the middle where i'm just like i know
i'm gonna find footage of you
as a child dancing because i know for
sure you did it he's like no i just
moved
his instincts are really great where cap
is very like
he has to know every single little
detail
michael likes like big picture to just
go and then i'm like that's great you
know
it's very weird it's like you become
this kind of sculptor of movements and
people in space
uh but yeah they're all over the place i
love it all right jane i warned you
you're next if everyone in the ensemble
doesn't necessarily have to be for the
musical numbers but whose process aligns
with yours the most and who challenges
you to adapt
maybe even for the better i personally
do not
picture the movie in my brain and then
try to recreate that like that's not
my process as an actress i'm not like i
want to hit this beat on this line
and i want to do that i want to be very
present
as present as possible and as alive as
possible in the moment and be surprised
so i guess i struggle with people whose
processes
are very much of i had this idea in my
brain and i really want the idea
but at the same time i i always find it
to be fun to sort of have to learn how
to work in someone else's process like
that can be
like a fun challenge in a way where i
mean that's what dancing became for me
dancing and singing because
i had never i've never done that i've
never lip sync on set while doing
choreography while trying to act
never done that in my life and so trying
to fit all those things together
in my own process of wanting to also be
like
free and mandy's very receptive of that
and gives me a lot of room to do that
and
um that process is really like wild it's
like it really feels like you're
stretching your creative muscles in your
brain
you know um so i'm not gonna call
anybody out and say that some people are
easier to work with than others but for
the most part
like it's a really collaborative easy
set
you know we we um
we work well together you could feel it
when you watch the show
mandy i have a selfish question for you
just because you were touching on it
before
i might be someone who's afraid to dance
and like i feel like that fear has
translated into me saying like i have no
interest
so what is like point number one the
first piece of advice you would give to
someone with that feeling
you can't do anything wrong in dance
who's to tell you you're doing it wrong
or right
something that if you want to flap your
arm over here and that feels good to you
great that's expressive that's dance you
know like i
really it's i'm gonna like i think it's
my life's work to figure out why people
are so afraid of dance like i don't
you know it's like when you i love to be
at a wedding and watch people dance that
don't move it's one of my favorite
things in the world like see somebody
start to like
feel good and you're like yes just keep
doing it you're amazing
no mirrors no no one's got an opinion
about it just feel it
you know and a lot of i mean jane could
probably agree with this but a lot of
our job as choreographers is to
help with competence right because it's
so much about how you're expressing the
confidence in whatever way
it is you know not necessarily that the
emotion is confidence but that
you are fully feeling what you're
supposed to be feeling it's not about
the shape
it's not about i can help you with shape
that's my life i can tell you how to
make that look better without your
shoulders up or like
without sticking your booty out like
jane and i have this thing right you
know i'm like
little fonda over there you're just
sticking your buns out there you know
it's like
that's stuff that i can help with that's
just technique you know but
it for me dance is just all about
feeling okay so you just gotta be
confident with it and
it is beautiful whatever you're doing
you are you and you're moving in the
space so it's great
i feel like there's a tick tock video in
the future of me just like flailing my
arms all over the place but
give it a shot i love it all right so
season two now and i know it's difficult
to talk about it and not get into
spoilers so just kind of broadly for
both of you
of everything you've already shot for
season two and everything you have on
the horizon is there any particular new
challenge that you are either most eager
to jump into yourself or most excited to
share with the
fans of the show everything that i do is
based off of the script right
so i just hope that fans continue along
the journey of what
this zoe world is you know it's
luckily austin has written a show that
allows
you know for me and my team a lot of
different lanes to go down
you know we express dance in a lot of
and we express feelings in a lot of
different ways on the show and so
you know for season two obviously
there's this feeling of like bigger
better but also on the other side like
more creative
more nuanced more layered more complex
what can we do with camera what can we
do with the
ins and outs of the moments you know we
were just talking about this the other
day of like
how do we get into these moments more
magically and take this
the audience on the ride with us you
know and
just yeah keep writing it awesome every
time a script comes out i'm like yes
let's do that i like this idea yeah
good thing like we're i'm starting to do
press again like this week has been
the beginning of press for season two
and last year
i did most of my press after we'd
finished shooting so it is a very
different experience to be in the middle
of the process and then talking about it
because i feel like in some ways i don't
even really know what it is yet you know
because i'm
i'm doing it and i'm not really somebody
that when i'm making something
i'm thinking about how the audience is
going to respond you know
i don't really have that producer brain
i'm just interested in like
telling the story as honestly and as
full and
vivid and dynamic as possible so that's
where my headspace is and so
i i'm not sure i can really
contextualize that
like and be like uh because i'm in it i
can't quite
see the process right now you know but
of course we're dealing with
a global pandemic so that has been um
challenging for many reasons just if
what the thing that i think about
all the time is just how much stress
everyone is under all the time
because of that and like how scared we
are
if i talk about it i'll get emotional
but it's like a really hard time so
um trying to maintain like just
normal feelings like while you're making
something that
i feel like we're gonna all collectively
look back at this time and be like wow
we were really
holding in a lot of stress and anxiety
you know i'm i'm a big believer that
that come the new year this show is
going to be
yet another source of kind of comfort
and good vibes i know it gave it to me
in the beginning of this year and then
re-watching it through your award season
campaign it did it all over again
so it's bound to happen in january too i
appreciate all the
the time and effort you guys are putting
into it right now
that makes me happy to know that people
feel something watching something we've
created it's like literally like makes
my heart
explode so thank you for that it makes
me sit in a puddle of tears but i
appreciate that so thank you
i did want to ask a little bit about the
nature of shooting the show
in a pandemic kind of two-fold here
maybe first just
like on a smaller scale what is
something that you were worried about
but like a little
i don't know maybe like a trick or a
hack you figured out to make you
feel like huh you know this change is
not so bad i can adapt to that
so many things are going on at once
where i'm like yes this is the new
normal
like it is the new normal to talk about
getting
i just i just worry that my experience
is so
far from someone else's and if i'm
gonna i i get concerned that like just
something instinctually inside of me is
like
i don't know i don't know if i feel okay
talking about
i don't know i don't know if i feel okay
talking about my like it's like i'm like
what if
someone else is having such a vastly
different experience that it's so
like trite or something for me to be
like well i was nervous about
this little you know i just feel so
blessed that i can work right now and i
know that's not what you're asking i
i just i'm so it's hard for me to
again i think it's because i'm in it to
really be like
everyone's a situation right now is is
very very
specific and unique and i think that
seems to be what you're getting at what
we do in production is such an
odd little thing that most people don't
even understand you know it's like
the kind of wizard behind the curtain
and
you know it is it is we would be silly
to say
it's not difficult to make this in the
pandemic it is but it's also something
that
you know i think humans in general are
resilient and humans are problem solvers
and humans are kind and compassionate
and patient
and that's what it takes to make things
you know so that is definitely happening
and
you know i guess yeah it can be scary
when you're outside of it not knowing so
of course there's like how are you going
to do this 14 hours a day how are you
going to
make every make sure everyone's safe
how's your team safe but
there's wonderful systems and protocols
and and we kind of adhere
to all of that and it feels like a
relatively
safe space emotionally and physically as
much as it can be you know
i'm only one person in the world
everybody else is a different
experience but following you on
instagram and seeing the behind the
scenes pictures you post
i feel like even seeing you guys keep at
it with some of those restrictions in
place
encourages me to maybe not sit in this
house all day and to suck it up and put
on a mask and get out into the world so
the things that you are sharing could
maybe nudge someone in a better
direction right now
i'm so happy to hear that that was also
basically a transition for me to admit
that i stalked your instagram and now
i'm wondering the season two have a cat
in it
no and it's also not my cat it was i i
i was just pretending i i stole
someone's cat and pretended it was mine
it was bad
um no i they so
there was a there was a litter of
kittens found somewhere in the city
and their mother had died and so people
were fostering these babies and
um bottle feeding them and so someone in
wardrobe
uh had this little kitten and
i got to hang out with him i also was
upstairs and i was stalking it too and
then i realized
she can't have a cat how's she having a
cat right now i'm gonna see her in like
five minutes and then i was like oh it's
not hers
although i do think in the future like i
think everyone's probably thought at one
point like
is zoe gonna hear an animal's song or
what
well now that's all i'm going to think
about
it's like it's mandy and jillian and
jeff in like a dog suit
like crafting their number we would do
it you know we really get in there like
to really try it out so we would do it
yeah have you ever seen the movie inside
out
the pixar movie i've grown mighty
obsessed with the end of it when you see
the emotions from the pet perspective
and now i need a whole nother movie
just like that totally that's such a
good film i love it
all right i have to let you guys go but
again huge congratulations on
season one i've seen the first episode
of season two i can tell people that and
you guys
if that episode is any indication you
have a lot to look forward to come
january 5th on nbc do check it out
again tell everybody you know about the
show they're going to thank you for it
jane mandy thank you again and big
congrats on everything
thank you perry love you janer
love you